est-ce qu'on perd ou est-ce qu'on gagne
une heure de sommeil c'est la question
que tout le monde se pose chaque dernier
week-end des mois de mars et d'octobre
depuis 1976 c'est la date à laquelle le
changement d'heure est entré en vigueur
en France métropolitaine une mesure
principalement mise en place pour faire
des économies d'énergie grâce à une
heure d'ensoleillement naturel de plus
le soir le pays se chauffait encore au
fioul et faisait face à ce moment-là un
choc pétrolier soit à une situation de
crise énergétique comme aujourd'hui
alors à l'heure de nouvelles tensions
autour de l'énergie faut-il maintenir le
changement d'heure la réponse dans ce
nouvel épisode de facture
pour soutenir le crâne l'Europe
sanctionne la Russie notamment en
réduisant ses importations de gaz russe
Vladimir Poutine utilise aussi son gaz
comme une arme stratégique en baissant
ses livraisons faisant flamber les prix
ou en coupant carrément le robinet à
certains pays la guerre en Ukraine fait
donc crainte des coupures de gaz et
d'électricité cet hiver car l'Europe
dépend beaucoup du gaz russe la France
doit de plus faire face à des arrêts en
cascade de ses réacteurs nucléaires le
gouvernement français a ainsi dévoilé au
début du mois d'octobre son plan
anti-gaspi pour éviter ce scénario
catastrophe et de covoiturage
usage de certains appareils comme la
machine à laver à des heures décalées
l'heure est à la sobriété énergétique
l'objectif réduire de 10% en deux ans la
consommation d'énergie du pays il s'agit
d'une première étape pour aboutir à une
baisse de 40% de cette même consommation
d'ici à 2050 dans ce contexte le
commissaire européen au Marché intérieur
breton a rappelé l'utilité du changement
d'heure
[Musique]
en 2009 les guerriers au changement
d'heure ont représenté près de 450
gigawh selon lame l'Agence de
l'environnement et de la maîtrise de
l'énergie c'est équivaut environ à la
consommation électrique de 800000
ménages donc on va dire l'agglomération
de Marseille accompagnée
d'Aix-en-Provence mais aujourd'hui ces
économies sont beaucoup plus modestes en
effet en 1996 elles étaient estimées à
1200 gigawh elle ne l'était plus
qu'après de 450 en 2009 et en 2030 elle
ne devrait plus représenter que 258
gigawh par an cette baisse elle est
notamment due à la généralisation de
l'éclairage à basse consommation si
aujourd'hui ces économies sont plus
modestes c'est aussi parce que les
villes et les ménages ont de nouveaux
équipements avec des éclairages à LED ou
par exemple les villes qui étaient un
éclairage la nuit toute la question
c'est qu'est-ce qui a changé dans déjà
dans l'équipement depuis est-ce que
l'éclairage est fait avec des lumières
qui sont plus ou moins efficaces et
qu'est-ce que en fait un terme aussi de
consommation d'électricité à augmenter
même son cloche du côté de la Commission
européenne qui l'assure aussi ses gains
sont marginaux en 2017 le service de
recherche du Parlement européen a estimé
que le changement d'heure permettrait
d'économiser entre 0,5 et 2,5% de la
consommation énergétique totale des pays
européens un an plus tard la Commission
européenne a d'ailleurs lancé une
consultation publique elle a reçu plus
de 4,6 millions de réponses et 84% ce
sont exprimés pour la suppression du
changement d'heure la Commission
européenne avait alors présenté un
projet de directive adopté en 2019 par
le Parlement européen chaque État devait
choisir de rester à l'heure d'été ou à
l'heure d'hiver mais en raison du
covid-19 et de la guerre en Ukraine le
projet n'a jamais abouti je pense que
l'urgence nous amène vers des questions
qui sont un peu plus fondamentales les
citoyens c'était quand même positionné
nettement contre les changements d'heure
on était en proportion de plus de 80%
donc je pense que sur ça il y a déjà un
consensus par contre il y a des gains et
des habitudes à changer sur les autres
usages de l'électricité et moi je pense
que c'est plutôt vers cette voilà qu'il
faut insister plus que réveiller en
arrière sur les changements d'heure
verdict le changement d'heure permet
bien de faire des économies d'énergie
mais les données scientifiques montrent
que ces gains se réduisent d'années en
année et sont aujourd'hui très modestes
dans le contexte actuel le gouvernement
le Martel chaque geste compte cependant
le changement d'heure ne semble pas être
une solution à la crise énergétique
plusieurs pays ont d'ailleurs déjà
abandonné cette mesure parmi eux la
Turquie l'Islande et même la Russie
[Musique]